cool so today I'll be giving a talk on
why software engineers disagree about
everything okay
my name is hasib Qureshi I'm a software
engineer at Airbnb I work on the wrist
team I'll be talking a lot more about
that and a lot more about kind of my own
history and the different different
things that I've done in my past because
that really informs a lot of what this
talk is about I don't know that I'll
totally answer the question of why
software engineers disagree about
everything but I think this talk is
gonna be kind of an exploration of this
question from a number of different
angles and another thing is gonna happen
in this talk is I'm going to disagree
pretty strongly with DHHS keynote so if
so that might be interesting but we'll
hopefully I'll at the very least if not
convince you of what I'm saying you know
maybe get you thinking about some things
so this talk in large part is going to
be about philosophy so I know you know
it's real scoffs usually people come up
here and they talk about controllers or
I guess someone else talking about
sorting and augmented reality I'm not
gonna be offended if you get up right
now and watch one or two another talk
that's totally cool but we are gonna go
way into the weeds today because that's
that's what I'm all about so
specifically I want to talk about the
field of philosophy known as
epistemology and epistemology the
easiest way to define epistemology is
epistemology is the nature of knowledge
of justification and of the rationality
of belief so this actually this diagram
here is of phrenology which is this old
science of you know trying to figure out
what parts the brain responsible for
what which is a very old and ancient
version of epistemology which we've now
thankfully displaced but centrally in
epistemology or there are the two
questions how does anyone know anything
and how do they know that they know it I
mean these two questions are kind of
navel-gazing
but that's that's fine so looky-loo
about me so i studied english and
philosophy in school and I before I ever
came in the tech world I used to be a
professional poker player and I did that
for about five years so you know I kind
of took a very different path into
programming than most people and then I
worked as a programming instructor I
taught programming at a coding bootcamp
and for the last little bit over a year
I've been working as an engineer on the
RISC team at Airbnb basically fighting
fraud and so because of this I've kind
of you know snaked my way through many
different subcultures I've been
something of a of a chameleon in that
I've learned the different norms and the
different beliefs and the different
knowledge systems that many different
worlds have and try to assure it on you
if you become a part of that world and
one thing that I've noticed and then you
can't help but notice the more of worlds
you step in and out of is that knowledge
is deeply cultural so in the world of
programming you know the kind of things
you might hear people tell you when you
come into this world
they might tell you that full set
javascript is the future they know this
for sure they'll tell you that everyone
should know see if you don't know see
what are you doing go out there you
crack open a book and learn some see
they'll tell you rust is the best
language for systems programming they'll
tell you that relational databases don't
scale they'll tell you that TDD is a
fantasy and nobody serious tries to do
it anymore
it's it's not it's not practical so now
all these are interesting questions
they're all things that people disagree
on obviously but they're people they're
things that people hold with very very
strong conviction that this is clearly
and just in a few tably true now I'm not
interested in convincing you of any of
these claims each of these could
probably be great talks themselves what
I'm interested in is why we disagree
about them why isn't that we all
converge on an answer to these questions
now it's funny because when I was in the
poker world I remembered this this was
very familiar to me when I was learning
how to be a poker player the
in the poker world people will tell you
things like No Limit is dying you have
to learn rich scams or they would tell
you everybody needs to use a HUD or they
would say only fish play lose passive
Styles they would say GTO is a fantasy
nobody actually plays like that and
there's a wonderful analogy between
these two worlds not just that people
argue a lot and then people are maybe
kind of whiny and excessive but that you
know they're there all these things that
people fundamentally disagree on and
each side of them holds tremendous
conviction that their side is clearly
and obviously correct and so when most
people hear stuff like this when they
hear someone say hey everybody should
know see and if you don't know see
you're not a real programmer their
natural reaction is oh god is that true
if that's true what should I do about it
but I for me having having gone through
this song and dance so many times my
reaction is why do they think they know
that and why what is it that implanted
so much confidence in them so much
conviction that the thing they're saying
is actually true and universally true
and that's very interesting to me it's
almost like I'm asking I tend to ask a
more evolutionary question than a
question about the world as it is right
now you know the thing that's kind of
weird about programming in particular is
that nobody agrees you know there's so
many things that people disagree on they
disagree about functional programming
object-oriented programming TDD all you
know robust proven frameworks shiny new
ones that solve new problems in
different ways serverless event-driven
bla bla bla bla right you guys you guys
know all this nobody agrees why
that's really weird now you might think
it's obvious that people don't agree
that's that's an understandable reaction
you might say like well you know
disagreement is a normal part of a
society and like you know the way that
we you know this this divergence is a
source of discourse and that's what we
end up having a healthy society so you
might think that's obvious so of course
people shouldn't agree I think it's
weird I think it's weird that people
don't agree and I want to develop in you
and intuition to also believe this is
weird that people don't agree because in
a way it makes more sense for people to
agree than for them to disagree another
way of putting what I'm saying is that
systems in general tend to converge when
you see a system you should assume that
over time it's going to converge on
what's optimal what's the sort of the
optimal State for that system let me
give you an example boom so I'm gonna
give you the example related to poker
but you don't need to know anything
about poker in order understand this I
can explain it in a couple sentences so
in poker
there's a strategy called set mining
okay and set my name is very simple so
in Texas Hold'em you get two cards and
if you want to set mine what you do is
you wait for two cards that make a pair
so let's say you get dealt a pair of
threes then what you do is you wait to
see if you make three of a kind you make
you have a kind you bet it really
aggressively and if you don't you just
fold that's set money
super super simple so step mining was
the strategy that was pretty simple and
pretty stupid almost anybody could do it
and it worked it worked really really
unreasonably well given how simple the
strategy was and so pretty soon what you
would see in the world of online poker
is that pretty soon when people started
talking about this almost everybody
started set mining at low to mid stakes
for ringgit
the strategy just took over like
wildfire
and well you could say is that the game
converged on set miner everybody saw
that set mining was the high ground and
they all moved in that direction and so
this is this is kind of one of the
features that happened to poker after
internet poker chip drops internet poker
took off really around 2004-2005 maybe a
little bit before that as well and if
you think about it before internet poker
ever existed there was live poker right
but playing poker in a brick-and-mortar
casino and live program was
fundamentally really different than
online poker in ways that people didn't
really predict before it happened so you
can imagine live poker you know let's
say in the 80s and 90s you know there
are some people playing poker out in
Phoenix maybe that people playing poker
in Vegas that people playing poker in
Dallas people playing poker in London
and these different groups of poker
players weren't really communicating
with each other you know ideas that were
germinating in London weren't you know
going over the pond and showing up in
card rooms in Dallas right people were
kind of isolated to their little group
so they were just playing poker and
figuring things out as they went but
with the advent of online poker and the
communication that it enabled for a lot
of people sorry there was like a fire
with the advent of that communication
what happened was that it allowed the
system to converge where suddenly
somebody has an idea for a strategy
somewhere in you know Dallas or New
Hampshire or whatever and suddenly they
can share it and everybody can learn
about this strategy very very quickly
and so what this meant was that the the
state of Poker strategy for a long time
it was pretty static the way that people
played in the 40s and 50s was not that
different from the way people played in
the 80's and 90's you know information
just wasn't able to evolve that
effectively but with the advent of
online poker suddenly if you if you look
at the curve of the complexity of Poker
strategy it just it just takes off right
after 2003 when online poker comes to
town and so right here is a graph
that audio is not playing that's fine
he's saying look at this graph this is a
joke that didn't play audio that's fine
I'm gonna roll with it so this is
actually a graph this is actually just a
graph that goes up into the right
there's nothing to with what I'm talking
about but I thought it would give a
sense of legitimacy to the slide it's
like oh this guy know that he's talking
about this graph cool so the point is
the point is all I know converged in a
way that that live poker never did it
was never able to and this to me is it
makes a lot of sense like of course
online poker is going to converge right
when you have these people able to
communicate to see what each other is
doing and move around in this terrain of
course they're gonna settle on what's
optimal and nature is full of convergent
systems like this so you know let's say
for example you're you're walking down
town and you you buy a loaf of bread
maybe you're French I don't know and
let's say you you eat half a loaf of
bread you toss the rest on the street
well what happens is pretty soon a bunch
of pigeons just it's not like they're
all in one place standing over watching
you throw the loaf of bread right but
pretty soon one pigeon comes three
pigeons come and then a chorus of
pigeons from presumably all over town
just come in and start you know just
just binging on the piece of bread that
you've left and this just kind of makes
sense right like the pigeons are able to
very quickly come down to whatever is
the optimal place for them to be they
they eat as much good as they can and
they disperse back to wherever was they
came from maybe to the next best piece
of food or they can find somewhere
downtown this example of a convergent
system so you know there's also this
great Rammstein album that actually I
loved when I was a kid it's not actually
just cell membrane in German because
that was the only I could find like 10
minutes ago but the the cell membrane
you guys might remember from high school
chemistry you know their water molecules
on one side they permeate through this
membrane and pretty soon you're the
exact same pressure the exact same
density of water molecules on each side
of the membrane in system convergence
and you see the same sort of thing in
stock markets a lot of natural
phenomenon it seems like this sort of
thing is everywhere
so when I started working as a risk
engineer at Airbnb working in the fraud
space naturally I started looking for
convergence - this seems like one of
those things that any any sufficiently a
complex system should eventually have
some optimal state and it should find
convergence so working in in in the
fraud industry is is its own little
subculture its own little world and the
Sun Pope is not just the subculture of
people working against fraud which is
which is interesting but that wasn't
really what fascinated me so much I mean
it is very interesting but the really
fascinating thing about fighting fraud
is that you're actively fighting against
a community of people you're actively
fighting against a culture that's
optimized to take you down and to
basically exploit your defenses as
effectively as they possibly can and so
you know really there is actually a
subculture that I can't see and don't
have direct access to that's organizing
and trying to attack all these you know
major online companies and they're
trying to make money and that's really
interesting and so I wondered you know
how do fraudsters figure out what to do
I mean what what they're learning is
pretty non-trivial right like they're
learning at a how to script how to do
you know sometimes cross-site request
forgery stuff XSS whatever the the code
with all these different ways to try to
probe our defenses and attack us and
ideally try to make some money how do
they learn this and how do they
communicate this to each other you know
how does how does this knowledge spread
in the world of fraud fundamentally the
question I want to ask is is there
convergence in fraud and this actually
pretty soon after the new MacBook Pro
replaced the Escape key we saw fraud go
way up so that was one person laughter
that was alright there we go there we go
a little just a little bit that's all I
need in order to keep going awesome so I
just want to run with you through a
quick example of kind of what a standard
frosting looks like this is this is some
site called
chipmunk does anyone know what chipmunk
is and we're familiar with this for this
steam company great then we're gonna
[ __ ] on them that's great
soo [ __ ] monkey let's say they cut some
corners they kind of it
feature they don't really know exactly
you know they're not really think about
frog when they implement this right like
some product manager is like hey you
know we've got the story we got to get
up the end of the week we're gonna all
look good once we fill this thing out
great engineers to work on this just
push it out don't really think too much
about it so this feature is essentially
some micro deposit where essentially
they verify that you own this account
because you they deposit to random
amounts you report them back right
pretty standard for some financial
institutions to do this sort of thing so
let's say that they don't implement rate
limiting easy thing to overlook well you
know they go to sleep at night feeling
great that they've launched this new
feature and pretty soon someone gets
alerted you know let's say at 2:00 a.m.
that night that somehow we've lost a
hundred thousand dollars which really
should not have happened and the only
way you could lose that amount of money
obviously is if fraudsters are at scale
repeatedly hitting this API repeatedly
micro depositing money into their
account and then just keeping it and so
people scramble you know people oh my
god I can't believe this going on
they go and they try to patch this hole
implement some rate limiting do some
rules maybe reverse whatever
transactions they can this is a common
type of attack that you know a very easy
vector that if you're a site influenced
something like this a kind of attack you
would be vulnerable to if you didn't
implement rate limiting so let's say
they get that under control that's fine
now what happens is that once you pass
that vulnerability of course the
fraudsters dispersed they don't keep
hitting it maybe they maybe they try to
verify that in fact it is patched they
try a few ways around it doesn't work
cool you've patched the vulnerability
and the fraudsters dispersed but kind of
like the pigeons they don't just go
randomly to different places and just
kind of you know leave your platform
what ends up happening is that they then
go to the next best place to defraud you
so with all new so far no key that
endpoint wasn't that good but there's
another thing that we can do like this
maybe longer more complex or more
expensive fraud scheme and we're gonna
go do that and basically what you see is
that the fraudsters
head down to the next highest peaks in
this terrain of fraud which you know
this this totally makes sense this is uh
this is convergent behavior right that's
exactly what you'd see if the terrain
suddenly changes peak became a valley
and they would go towards the next
highest peak so this seems
like convergent behavior seems like
fraudsters converge on what's optimal
but the more as I thought about this the
more I realized that this didn't totally
make sense and the reason that this
totally didn't make sense because I
asked the question why are they
defrauding us at all why are any
fraudsters attacking shipment this may
seem like a weird question right look of
course they're doing it so that they can
make money and that's what fraudsters
are motivated by but if you think about
it the the terrain of all the companies
that they can defraud is huge there are
many many many companies that are
vulnerable to fraud and pretty much all
of these companies experience fraud to
one degree or another right there all
these different sites that you could
attack if you so wanted and so what you
would what do you what you can say is
that there's some topology to that fraud
right there's some peaks and valleys
there's some there's some sites that are
really really lucrative to the fraud and
other ones that you know really not so
much and they're not a good place to be
spending your time if you're a fraud
suit and so you'd think that everybody
would converge on the peaks what you
think is that almost all the fraud would
go towards the very most profitable most
attackable web sites but what you see
instead is that fraud that is just kind
of dispersed everywhere they're just
sort of ambient level of fraud that if
you start an e-commerce site chances are
you're gonna get some amount of fraud
why this is weird this should strike you
as weird why is it like those fraudsters
just don't care about optimizing are
they not trying to make the best use of
their time is there something that
they're misapprehend about the terrain
like what's going on that we don't see
this convergent behavior within fraud
now you know it occurred to me that
actually you see the same sort of thing
in software you know even just looking
at open source solutions there's so many
different software packages there's so
many different open source solutions to
many many different problems that are
effectively you know trying to do the
exact same thing
why it seems like software doesn't
converge either well you don't get this
just one okay this is the best way to
solve this problem and everybody
converges on that solution what you see
instead is many many many competing
solutions and it's not really clear
which one is supposed to win and when
one does win it's actually really
surprising you know like so you know
react you could say kind of one front
end you aizen so far as you can say any
one one friend and you is uh and we're
genuinely amazed by that on some meta
levels like oh [ __ ] someone won no one
ever wins anything anymore but react
just one front end you eyes you know and
you know maybe maybe that kind of
relaxes you because you're like oh hey
you know as long as I don't react I'll
just be employable forever and you know
that's fine
but I think this is this is somewhat
counterintuitive that more things aren't
like this why is this such a rare story
that react wins or sequel wins or one
particular way of solving a problem just
is clearly the best and we all adopt it
so you might have an obvious objection
to this analysis which would be that
well of course you know things aren't
going to converge because software
doesn't just solve one problem right the
obvious answer is that they're they're
actually multiple terrains so you know
you could say that there's a terrain for
prod apps and that looks different and
then there's a terrain for the payments
backends and then one for social
networks and maybe the tools and the
solutions that you use for these
different apps are different and that's
why you see this this you know these
multifarious solutions to effectively
the same problem but I I don't think
that's that's sufficient because even
within a single terrain you don't see
convergence you know even just looking
at credits right perhaps are you know
they're the majority of what people
build that's a majority of web apps are
just you know glorified credits maybe
with like elasticsearch there on top and
like because of the vast majority of
what people build there's a vast
majority of what people disagree on so
it doesn't seem to me like that's
satisfactory to explain why we don't see
convergence
and the thing is you should want
convergence convergence is actually good
because convergence means that we all
see the underlying terrain we all
understand it and therefore we all go
and do the best thing in the world of
software for the most part we're not
actually competing with each other we're
actually all kind of at least to some
degree or another motivated by each
other succeeded you know when someone
invents a great open source solution
actually everybody benefits from that
and most software kind of works this way
so the question I want to ask is why do
these systems not converge I think there
are four reasons and I'm going to go
through each of them so the first reason
why these systems don't necessarily
converge is because the terrain is
actually unstable the terrain is
changing it's not just one configuration
that you can just see it or see
something out in the distance decide ok
that's a peak I'm gonna go over that
right the fact that the terrain is
changing means that you're not really
sure if you do go in this direction that
by the time you get there the terrain
isn't going to be different right it
also means of course that your terrain
is moving underneath you so by the time
that you when you originally came into
Ruby on Rails we thought wow this is the
hottest newest shiniest web framework
anyone has ever come up with and now
it's 2017 and rails is not the shiniest
newest coolest framework that anyone has
ever come up with
and so the terrain has changed
underneath you and that makes it hard
for people to actually converge when
there's so much change going on there
was this article that someone wrote on
medium a little while back how it feels
to learn JavaScript in 2016 you didn't
read this article I'm sure you have an
intuition of what this thing said right
and we we see this coming more and more
I don't want to say a problem but more
and more of a characteristic of software
the things are changing very rapidly and
it might be that that pace of change is
even increasing which wouldn't be
wouldn't be that unreasonable to expect
actually as technology grows more and
more rapidly and you see the same sort
of thing in the world of fraud so say
for example that you know Facebook has
some
at whole some kind of things that
fraudsters can attack let's say it comes
really easy to spam Facebook and you
know do some kind of referral click
fraud whatever whatever stuff so maybe
you know if you're a fraud sir you're
making $20 an hour defrauding Facebook
doing this well Facebook goes in and
they patch the hole and now you know
instead of making $20 an hour you can
only make $3 now but in order for the
fraudsters to disperse and find the next
highest thing you know they they they
might be just incentivized to say like
hey I don't actually know how easy it's
gonna be to defraud anything else
because that might get patch two and
that might you know the terrain might
just change out underneath me so you
know what I'll just keep the photic
Facebook for $3 an hour that's fine like
I say that this is working during the
time that I have it so maybe that's
that's some part of the explanation why
you don't see this optimizing across
across the terrain so the second reason
why I think you see a lack of
convergence in some of these domains is
because of high switching costs okay so
let's say that this is the domain that
let's say this is software this is the
map of the software world and let's say
that you live all the way on the bottom
right and the bottom right let's say is
rails land and you know you go and talk
to some wide eyed bushy tailed developer
who tells me you know what you you just
need to learn Haskell and if you learn
Haskell you know all these type errors
and nil checks I'm not Anna all that
stuff is gonna go away and you were
gonna live in a land of just pure
programming bliss nothing will ever go
wrong your code will be way more
performant you know you are just gonna
yeah whatever things gonna be great the
problem with that of course is that for
you to actually engage in that switch
let's say even you see what this person
tells you and you agree with them but
this peak that they're pointing to is
very very far away so in order for you
to get there you got to go down into a
valley traverse a really really long
space until you can finally actually
reap the fruits of what they were
claiming was so great and who knows
because the terrain is changing by the
time you get there it might not even be
a peak anymore something else better
become a peak or maybe the place where
you were at could have become a peak who
knows and so this this instability and
this uncertainty makes people really
unwilling to incur the risk of
traversing the terrain and exploring
you see of course the same thing in
fraud this I just mentioned with with
the Facebook example and this whole
thing of course is exacerbated by
specialization the more specialized you
are the harder it's going to be for you
to convince yourself to engage in those
high switching paths right it's really
specialization is just basically you
finding your way to some local maximum
that's what specialization is it's
climbing as high as you can onto a local
maximum
once you're there it just becomes really
uncompelled to climb all the way down
from that peak of specialization you've
arrived at to go find the true global
maximum which might be very far away and
you know we've already talked about the
fact that it's changing and uncertain
and so this makes it harder the more
specialized we are same thing with
fraudsters they're fraudsters who are
specialized and you know attacking one
side as opposed to another and it's hard
for them to switch if we learn a lot of
new things they have to start over in
their knowledge so as a third reason why
I think you don't see convergence and
fraud or in software or in these other
fields is information sharing is a very
important part of how you get
convergence right if you think about it
not all of us can actually clearly
elusively see that underlying terrain
you know there are these peaks and
valleys we know they're there but
there's sort of like a fog of war right
and that we can't see just kind of
beyond our local environment you just
don't know a month not much about what
Haskell Mountain looks like or what you
know some other language or framework
that you're not familiar with so in
order for us to really get that sense of
where the terrain is like we have to
share information with each other about
what the terrain is that's that's how we
learn what happens if we go out far
enough into the terrain and whether the
costs are going to be worth it
so different cultures have different
amounts of information sharing and that
makes it harder or easier for them to
converge on different things so if you
if you imagine this if you imagine a
graph of different cultures you can sort
of graph them on how close were just
open they are in terms of information
sharing so if you look at a very very
closed system a good example of this is
the fraud industry so if you're a
fraudster
then actually it's very hard to learn
and get access to the information that
you need in order to learn how the
I'm a fraudster right so they're all
these underground fraud industry so
fraud is an industry in many places in
the world where basically you can you
can you know get access to courses you
can buy them you can get primers on how
to hack this site or that site you their
various tools you can buy you can pirate
whatever there's all the stuff you need
to get up and running as a fraudster and
it's not easy to get this stuff you
actually have to you know make your way
into communities you have to prove
yourself you have to gain reputation you
can't just decide hey you know I'm gonna
go on Amazon and buy a text book on how
to commit fraud right it doesn't exist
you can't do that you have to go in
through a very specialized way and not
all information is actually readily up
for grabs there are some fraud ratings
they just don't share that information
with anyone outside of it and it's not
for sale and so that makes it very
difficult if you're somebody who's
wanting to learn more about fraud to
actually figure out what is the optimal
place for me to be spending my time
defrauding people now somewhat more on
the open side is you could look at a
world like poker
so poker is kind of a more open system
you know so they're all these forums
they're different places where people
can exchange ideas
there's certainly books written about
poker that you can just buy if you want
to but the very best players the very
best ideas the very best theories and
strategies about poker they're generally
not for sale you know the people who
hold them and the people who profit the
most from them tend to keep them close
to the chest so you get a lot of you get
a lot of resources that are okay or that
are really crappy that are openly
available but the very best stuff
sometimes it's hard to find and hard to
actually gain value from and then the
other hand if you look all the way to
the right you find the software the worm
software is in a lot of ways kind of
staggeringly open you know you have
companies that are just releasing the
source code for their entire application
or security libraries that are again
like completely open source and
companies are just saying yeah we use
open SSL movie if you find a weakness to
open SSL that's a weakness in us right
and this is this is really about as open
as you can get and their blog posts
there are all these things that are
shared about about software that make it
seem like wow there's an enormous amount
of information sharing that should
really make it so that people see really
quickly what is actually the best
solution for any different problem
somehow in the world of software it
doesn't really seem like that happens
all that well and so I don't know I
think there's somewhat of an open
question
even though there is a lot of sharing on
the surface if in fact there are some
things that people aren't that open
about sharing like you know I think when
it comes to what a lot of large
companies are doing when there's sort of
putting together a lot of open source
solutions to solve problems they
actually don't immediately go out and
tell people oh hey we solved this
problem here's how we did it very often
the way that companies share this
information is pretty selective and
pretty strategic and the moment you
solve a cutting-edge problem you
generally don't go out and share it
unless you think there's some strategic
value in doing so and so that I think to
some degree kind of exacerbates the
problem of why is it that we don't get
this convergence in the world of
software so reason number four and I
think this is a really interesting
reason that kind of goes to sociology is
basically the problem of group
identities and we heard some dysmorphia
chech from DHS about the value of group
identities and I'm kind of gonna go at
it from a completely different angle I'm
going to talk about more the dangers of
group identities so you can imagine that
the world of programming is kind of you
know it's demarcated these different
kind of arbitrary groups okay one of the
groups might be Rubeus or you know rails
programmers or whatever which you can
you know you categorize myself in there
then you know you have Java lovers over
here Python Easter's over here and then
Scala's over there and it's there
they're currently special norms that
dictate what you can do inside these
different worlds if you want to fit in
into these groups you know these groups
kind of say look well you're a Java
lover you can explore this area but
you're not really you don't really feel
so go over there that's kind of weird
stuff that we don't really do in Java
lab right and so you get these kind of
arbitrary cuts a process terrain that
make it hard for you to just freely
traverse and explore this terrain
without violating some kind of social
norm associated with your group turns
out you get the same kind of thing with
fraud rates right so there's a fraud
ring that just defrauds Facebook and
that's all they do and all they do is
that you know they're they're talking on
some sort of you know secret channel
where only fraudsters that are part of
this group can communicate and they
share information about just how to
defraud uber or just how to defraud
Google and if you're one of the members
of the other groups maybe you can't get
into that group
the processor just decided no we're with
this group and you're that group and
you're not gonna get our information and
so if you want to explore you only get
to explore the terrain over there you
know and I think in the world of
software you kind of see this when you
know instead of having like an
explanation of blog post it's just
here's how Kafka works there's the blog
post cops go up for rails engineers
right or the blog posts you know X Y Z
for Rubeus and this again is like kind
of reinforcing that demarcation that hey
you know I know you want to go to
explore that so let me show it to you in
the way that's appropriate for our group
and I think this is really fascinating
to me because you know being somebody
who's relatively new to the subculture
of software I could immediately
recognize this behavior and I think it's
pretty well explained by this theory in
psychology called
social identity theory so the idea of
social identity theory it's pretty
simple
essentially suggests that the way that
we construct our identities as human
beings is largely as a result of the
groups that we adhere to so this is kind
of goes in several stages the first
thing you do is you start categorizing
the world into social groups okay so you
first have to say okay so these people
are the Christians these people are the
Goths these people are the meatlovers
okay whatever whatever you want to how
do we want to draw up those boundaries
in the space of what people can be so
first you have to draw those boundaries
next you have to identify which of those
groups you belong to you know do I want
to be do I want to be meat lover do I
want to be a Python sir do I want to be
somebody who loves red or whatever you
have to decide which of those groups
you're gonna identify with okay then
once you do that the last step is social
comparison now you have to do the pretty
hard work of deciding why the other
groups are bad and your group is good
you have to make this distinction
between your in-group and the out group
and invent some kind of story or
narrative that goes along and reinforces
why you're good and they're bad so you
know there are all these classic
examples of this sort of thing where
basically there's some arbitrary
distinction that you've arrived on as
being important to your social
identification and you know there's no
intrinsic reason why that's
to be important but you know where
Rubeus and their java lovers and because
of that they're bad and we're good
and we have to come up with some sort of
story why that's the casein they have to
do the exact same thing now you might be
the social identity theory would suggest
that okay well that should mean that all
rubyists and all rails developers are
the same but i don't really feel like
that i'm not the same as the people
around me and if you look around people
right like you know you all don't look
like a completely homogeneous group of
people and this is this is true and so
there's another theory that kind of
complements this really well and it's
called differential psychology a
differential psychology essentially
examines the way that people within
groups try to make themselves different
from each other as a way of somehow
strengthening their bond is being a part
of that group so for example if you ever
seen the movie West Side Story so you
look at these characters they're all
part of a gang in West Side Story they
all you know they they're all together
part of the same group you can tell they
could've have a look right if you just
saw these people instead you feel ok
these people are doing something
together there's some something that
somehow unites them but notice they
don't all wear exactly the same outfit
and they could they could always the
exact same outfit they could all style
their hair the exact same way but they
don't
why don't they why don't they do that
you'd think that maybe that would
strengthen their group identity if they
all literally did the exact same thing
they would be a stronger part of that
group but it turns out there's something
intrinsic to us as human beings that
even though we're a part of groups it's
important for us to differentiate
ourselves we actually spend a
significant amount of energy just
differentiating ourselves within the
groups that were in as a way of almost
masking our identities within that group
right and so way to not make ourselves
feel that like hey I don't have any
identity outside this group because I
seem to be wearing the exact same thing
everyone else is wearing and doing the
exact same thing everyone else is doing
will expend a lot of energy in order not
to feel that so that's exactly what you
see these people in West Side Story
doing and so I want to draw a little bit
Knology here is that there's something
kind of similar going on when you look
at something like this where we're
expending this energy you know if you
imagine this underlying terrain of you
know software and let's say this right
here is rails Mountain there's a lot of
energy going into making it so that
you know it kind of looks like we're
exploring this big terrain but really
everything is actually still in the
bounds of this group even though we're
talking about you know Kafka or elixir
or whatever it is we're still keeping
you as a part of this group and that
identity is actually reinforced by you
being here in every single way even the
fact that you're going to these
different talks talking about different
technologies you're still seeing it as a
rails developer
and I think this is bad I think this
masks the severity of the problem of
social identities making it harder for
us to actually converge and actually
find what is genuinely optimal it allows
us to kind of distract ourselves in the
story but like hey we're exploring these
different things really underlying it
we're not so I think we should really
want to find convergence we should want
to find the true global maximum so as
software engineers what what ought we to
do about this and I don't know that I
have perfect answers to this I think
these are all really intrinsically hard
problems but I do have a couple of
pieces of advice that hopefully might be
instructive to some degree so the first
piece of advice is an adage from paul
Grammer and initially where he said keep
your identity small and really kind of
what this means is to as much as you can
as much as possible jettison the labels
that you've that you've very easily come
to identify yourself with and so that's
to say you know don't think of yourself
as a rails developer or as a ruby
developer but instead think of yourself
as a software engineer such that
whatever ends up being the right tool
for the job and that tool might be rails
might or might be Ruby might be
something else that's what you
fundamentally use you solve problems in
the world of software and right now it
might be very beneficial for you to go
climbing up this hill of learning more
about rails or more about Ruby but
eventually you will not be you can
imagine ten years from now you'll be
working on something and rails probably
won't be the tool you want to use ten
years from now in fact I would right now
I actually consider myself to be I love
Ruby I love Rails I think they're really
awesome and wonderful tools but I would
be probably pretty disappointed myself
if I was a rails developer ten years
from now and that was what I consider
myself to be I'm a rails developer you
know when when DHH was talking about the
code the article about
programmers that you know there are
people still making money for banks
working on these super antiquated COBOL
applications you can bet that there will
still be rails apps ten years from now
and I'm sure that you'll probably
although fetch a pretty penny you know
basically managing these ten year old 12
year old 15 year old rails apps but is
that fundamentally what you want to be
doing or is what you want to be doing to
solve problems with software however
those problems end up changing and
however those tools end up changing the
second piece of advice I want to give
besides keeping your identity small is
pretty obvious it's just to explore the
terrain and exploring the terrain to me
it means more than just kind of you know
paying lip service to different things
okay I don't know what tough day is I'm
gonna go to this talk I'm gonna go to
that talk
it means fundamentally to do things
you've never done before
okay it needs to do things that are kind
of scary to you it means to take real
risks and when I say real risks I'm just
opposing that against fake risks which I
think are a real thing and something you
should caution yourself against a fake
risk is one where you actually retain
all of your safety all of your comfort
all of your prestige all of your
knowledge all of your abilities or it's
like you know what I'm still a really
awesome person everyone respects me I
know everything that I'm doing but I'm
also taking this risk no you're not no
you're not right the risk comes when you
give up you actually walk down the hill
and walking down a hill is uncomfortable
it's scary
it makes you nervous and if you're not
actually doing that then you're not
really taking a genuine risk another way
of saying this is go to Jango Khan don't
actually go to Jakarta probably sucks
but there's probably like if if
railsconf is the only conference you're
going through this year reflect on that
reflect on what that means whether it
means that you are actually taking risks
that are important so and finally of
course I think the most important part
of exploration is just to have fun and
when you let go the idea that you
constantly need to be moving up and that
in fact it's okay
to move down and to take risks in a way
that potentially make it harder for you
to get your job done but that's okay in
that and
allow yourself to have fun doing it and
I think that makes the whole process a
lot easier so that's it for me
I'm received Qureshi a software engineer
on risk it Airbnb if you're a senior
software engineer or a data scientist
we're always hiring and yeah thanks for
listening
[Applause]